hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra Jessa and today I went
and saw rampage on Twitter as like oh
man vote for what you think I should see
there's not much coming out this week
and I thought I was gonna go see
breaking in that got the least amount of
votes and then I feel pretty was in
second place which was a shock to me I
honestly think that I would like I feel
pretty when I finally see it I think
I'll probably really like it but I
thought I don't know I aren't people
hating on that film maybe that's why
they wanted me to see it anyways rampage
won by a landslide and I'm a bit
concerned because it's been out for a
few weeks that it might not do well you
know something you think about it's a
tuber but it did so well in the vote
it's a video game film it's got the rock
in it and it looks like a stupid fun
movie so alright I knew that I was going
to like it but I did not know to the
extent at which I was going to like it
I loved it the rock is just everything
he touches is gold but like cheesy gold
like fun
cheesy stupid lovely heartfelt gold I
will say this there's definitely gonna
be spoilers in this though this isn't
like a Star Wars film this isn't you
know infinity war I don't think that me
spoiling things is gonna really spoil
anything it's just is an action flick
about a video game gorillas and
crocodile and wolf a wolf they can fly
but a wolf nonetheless so I've played
rampage before it's kind of a fun twist
on the whole monster idea it's where
you're playing as the monster instead of
the military trying to take down the
monsters you're trying to take down the
cities and you get to advance in levels
when you turn the city into rubble super
fun easy enough concept and they did
such a good job this might be what this
is one of the best video game movies
I've ever seen ever ever this movie was
super full of action
had decent enough characters that you
cared about what happened to them even
though they were generic and even though
a lot of the writing was really
run-of-the-mill action for some reason
it's super worked and and all of these
people were just like I said just very
generic but in the best way and some of
the references that they made we're like
almost calling out this type of movie
and it was amazing it was so good it was
so much fun I cannot believe the amount
of fun that I had I know Malcolm was
telling me that he really liked it I
know a lot of people online said that
they just loved it it's like yeah I know
I know I'm definitely gonna enjoy it but
man I did not know I thought I knew
didn't know it starts in space which is
a great way to start a generic action
film that rules and it has just such a
silly tone like everything's serious and
you have things going wrong are
definitely going wrong but it starts
with such a silly tone it really just
gives the film permission to just be
it's silly action II self and and you
you you're okay with it feels like
you're laughing with them not at them
and also the rock is just a film goddess
and he did such a good job in this and
there was even a point at the end where
I'm like oh man I really wish you would
have cried
I wish the very end he thinks that
George is dead I wanted him to cry as
his best friend he doesn't like people
because his character is so generic that
he's like Mia people just don't get me I
really just get along with animals
that's why I have such a strong bond
with this khont know it's best for a
worked and also it's his best friend I
wanted him to cry when his best friend
was dead you know what I mean and he
didn't okay I don't really care it's
still works
a gorilla flicks off the rock in the
first five minutes of the movie so yeah
it's a 10 if I remember correctly in the
game it was scientists that turned into
these big animals am I making that up
am I crazy with that in this it's the
space rocks from the space scene in the
beginning fall on to three specific
animals on earth and
turn into these giant monsters that's
attacking the city so they already start
off as animals and then they're just
plagued with space rock you know right
it's just science
then you're introduced to the villains
who are played by young Jim and the girl
that plays the sister in all
romantic comedies and I'm very on board
I love it they're a very good duo
they're so dramatic in the way that
they're villains especially the the
female character and I am here for it so
you get George's first big freakout and
every single monster movie where
somebody has a connection with an animal
and he's trying to calm down the animal
cops come and ruin it with guns stop
shooting
a giant animals that are ruining the
city like it's your job it is it is your
job but stop so then you see the giant
wolf and the wolf is attacking people
let's call the giant wolf Cheryl Cheryl
is attacking the city and Cheryl's just
gonna go ahead and eat y'all Cheryl's
not messing around that I just wrote
well okay actually they started calling
him off which is I have to admit even
better than Cheryl so we're gonna go
through so because the rock is trying to
help out George he gets captured by the
government obviously and they zip tie
his arms together and he just breaks out
at one point and I was very impressed
until I remembered I have seen a YouTube
tutorial showing you how to break out of
his it time it looked pretty easy so me
try it
not impressive the rock pretty sure I
didn't do that right so you've got giant
Gorge giant Ralph's
and now a giant alligator attacking
Chicago which if there's anything that's
giant and from Florida that's ten times
scarier than it already was going to be
again just that's science I love that
this was set in Chicago I didn't realize
it was going to be set in Chicago it was
a surprise when I sat down and was
watching the film and I adored it I
don't think I've ever seen a monster
movie set in Chicago like oh my gosh
they just ruins the giant Dave &
Buster's downtown hilarious never been
more of like a bar arcade type of girl
but I know that place again the movie
tropes with the character are so funny
it's like yeah I just get along with
animals so much and I'm sensitive and
I'm strong like I'm very toned and
strong and I've got a really good moral
compass
oh forget what I said about I don't get
along with people because the romantic
lead just gets me she just just gets me
but I love it it works it works so well
so the romantic lead and the rock are
looking for an antidote to help get rid
of the aggression that George has so
that George can help take down the other
two monsters and hopefully put an end to
this destruction of Chicago they're
looking for the antidote and it's called
an RPG she's like look for anything
labeled RPG and I was my favorite part
of the movie was such an easy simple
little thing Jeffrey Dean Morgan played
agent Russell who was like the tough but
slightly funny cowboy CIA agent FBI
agent I don't know what kind of agent he
was but he was a delight he was so funny
and again so so typical of these types
of movies but was great I loved him I
wrote I mean what the hell he rides a
broken helicopter down a tumbling
skyscraper like an avalanche I think I'm
in love
honestly the rock is not my type but
maybe now he is George
little preview over the film if you
haven't seen it any film that has a
powerful military character who doesn't
even have a name I don't think yell
abort mission
it's just well usually it's really bad
honestly but this time it was it was a
real fun it was real hoot even the very
end was just so cheesy you know he
thinks it his girlfriend is dead and
then his gorilla friends like haha
joke's on you buddy I'm not dead and
it's it's real cheesy and the girl is
like are you crying and rocks like I'm
not crying he wasn't actually really
crying but it it was the gorilla
you know George hit song the romantic
lead for him and you know it's a whole
thing and I loved it
this movie has been out for a while and
I've been sleeping on it by not seeing
it immediately it was so much fun it's
super worth going go on $5 Tuesday's or
whatever theaters do that go get a movie
pass while you still can
movie pass please don't go go watch this
movie it was so much fun I had popcorn
and I got a side of cheese to dip my
popcorn in just like next-level it
was great it was really fun I super
recommend to this movie thank you so
much for watching I have got some really
exciting weeks coming up with solo and
Deadpool too and and so bigger movies
are coming these last two weeks have
been just there's not much going on yeah
thank you so much for watching I'll see
ya next week bye
you
[Music]